سواء كان هجوما مشتركا او احاديا الثابت
انه لا يمكن لايران ان تمتلك سلاحا نوويا
تل ابيب وواشف تؤكدان المؤكد والمؤكد ايضا
ان مسيرات ايران في اوكرانيا باتت تستنفذ
الصبر الاستراتيجيه الامريكي تجاهها وتحفز
عقيده الاخطبوط الاسرائيلي الاستراتيجيه
لرئيس الوزراء السابق بنت باستهداف ايران
وليس فقط اذرعها من افضل منا تنياهو
لتطبيقها في الحقيقه هو اكثر من يعرف عن
ايران وطموحاتها النوويه منذ 2019
50,000 صفحه
اضافه الى 55 الف ملف اخر حملت على 183
قرصا مضغوطا
اولا ايران تزعم انها لا تمتلك برنامجا
نوويا عسكريا
لكن 150 الف ملف سري تثبت العكس
ثانيا حتى بعد الاتفاق النووي ايران
واصاله تطوير وتوسيع برنامجها النووي
لاستعمالها في المستقبل السؤال لماذا
يحاول نظام ارهابي اخفاء الملفات النوويه
لاستعمالها في المستقبل ثالثا
الولايات المتحده تعرف الكثير ايضا
فالوصول الى ارش في ايران النووي كما
شاهدناه كان جهدا امريكيا اسرائيليا
مشتركا وهذا ما اكده
السابق في كتابه وعلى ضوء المكشوف
والمعروف وقع هجوم المسيرات على اربعه
مواقع لكن يجدر الوقوف عند هجوم اصفهان
ليس للجدل الدائر حول نجاح العمليه وصعوبه
مطابقه الصور التي نشرتها السلطات
الايرانيه والتي بالكاد تظهر اي تاثير
وبينما رصدته كاميرات الايرانيين لحظه
وقوع الهجوم الوقفه هنا تتعلق
بطبيعه الموقع مركز ابحاث الفضاء وهنا
ووفقا للاستخبارات الاسرائيليه مصنع
لتصنيع صواريخ باليستيا مقلقه لماذا
الى جانب السريه التي تحيط بمواقع عسكريه
عده وسنفصلها بعد قليل تقدر التل ابيب
امكانيه تصنيع ايران لصواريخ قادره على
حمل رؤوس النوويه خلال عامين منطلقها من
مركز الفضاء او المصنع في حرمه وذلك لان
المشتبه بهما هما زولجانا وقائم 100
صاروخاني لاطلاق الاقمار الصناعيه
الايرانيه يجرى تطوير نسخ عسكريه منها
وصحيفتها ارت نقلت المزيد من التفاصيل عن
المسؤولين العمليه ستمكن الصاروخين من حمل
راس نووي بوزنه نصفه والوصول الى مسافه
تتجاوز 4000 كيلو متر